in this video we'll talk about kineto
course kinetocores are protein-rich
assemblies found around the centromere
of a metaphysic chromosome
in this picture you can see the
centromere region in red and the
associated protein-rich structure is the
kinetochore which is quite integrate and
contains several different proteins
segregation of a replicated genome
during the cell division requires the
kinetocore for linking the spindle
microtubule to the centromeric DNA and
this particular assembly ensures proper
segregation of the chromosome so in the
metaphagic chromosome the microtubules
need to attach in the region of the
centromere especially the kineticore and
thereby things get separated
so if this separate separation doesn't
happen properly then there could be
difference in ploidy so defective
segregation can lead to many uh genetic
defects that is why
somebody or some mechanism need to
assemble the microtubule firmly
and equally with the centromeric region
kind of kineticore proteins ensure this
phenomena
so what we know today about kinetukur
came from the electron microscopic
observation at early 1970s
so if you look at these blurry picture
from electron microscopy a trend I can
understand there are at least three
different layers
and these are some microtubules in this
electron micrograph but anyway with the
further development of proteomic
Technologies it is now known there are
several hundreds of proteins which are
associated in the kineticode region
so it's a huge protein assembly and its
key job is to assemble the microtubules
with the centromeric region so there are
three sub-regions of the kinetochord the
inner kinetochore the outer kineticore
and the outer fibrous layer the outer
fibrous layer ensures it can attract
microtubules towards the centromedic
region
so recent Studies have found that there
are more than 80 kinetoco
protein components there are many other
indirect interactors as well
so out of the many proteins the key
protein components of the kinetochore
are the ndc80 complex the simp e and the
dam one ring complex these are few very
important components of the kinetic code
but when we imagine the kinetochore we
should not picture it as a static
structure over the cell division
in different phases of cell division
kinetochord protein composition changes
if we look at metaphase telophase
interface
we would find there are some common
proteins present throughout but there
are specific proteins present in
specific phase of the cell cycle and it
has functional implication we'll try to
understand how
so this is late metaphase
so at the late metaphase and the
beginning of the anaphase the
chromosomes need to be separated but
these chromosomes are bound tightly with
the structural maintenance of Chromatin
protein the the condensines and the
cohesives so obviously it cannot be
separated by the way apcs
ours anaphase promoting complex that can
inhibit securing and release separases
which can break down these uh
condensines or cohesive rings and
thereby allow the chromosome separation
during the anaphase point of time so
this is the normal scenario now in the
condition where there is a abnormal
tension or there are microtubule
attachment defect let's see what happens
so there are tension tension sensor
proteins
in the kineto core region or in the
overall centromeric region which can
sense a disbalance of tension between
two sides and these tension sensors
convey a message with several might
several components of the kinetic code
some of the major ones are mad one mad
two mad three Bob one all of these
proteins the key job of these proteins
is to inhibit the
anaphase promoting complex and thereby
it can inhibit the breakdown of the
cohesive rings and preventing the
separation of chromosomes this is how
kinetoco proteins play a key role
I hope this was clear if you like this
video give it a quick thumbs up don't
forget to like share and subscribe you
can follow us on Facebook or Instagram
you can get more notes and flashcards
you can support our Channel with super
thanks
and you can pay via paytm UPI or even
net banking see you in next video